so the simple question is do you believe  in equal pay  [Music]  he's answered this so many times kathy  oh i made the argument there so it  depends so you don't believe in equal  pay  no i'm not saying that at all because a  lot of people listening to you will just  say i mean are we going back to the  doctor that's correct you're actually  not listening i'm just being pretty  carefully and i'm hearing  basically  are you listening very carefully because  are you kathy you have asked him things  like oh so you don't believe in he's  like i never said that oh so would you  celebrate that why why wouldn't he i  don't think you're listening to me i  don't think she's listening at all she  wants to get her  her questions out and her point